time to talk about cheating in chess for
those of you who've been under a rock
there's been a ton of stuff happening in
the online chess world including a 14th
world champion who has become a
self-proclaimed expert on uh on on
cheating statistics um he's Vladimir is
actually amazing shout out to Vlad and
we deeply respect him believe it or not
this is not going to be a segment where
I'm even necessarily defending chest.com
or making disparaging jokes at the 14th
world champions expense we respect him
in his opinion we respect iano Carana
his opinion the C squ podcast we respect
everyone in their opinion and I want to
start off with saying that in this
segment the first thing that really
really matters is is giving a massive
validation sandwich to everybody who has
been frustrated at times with how
chess.com has handled the process of
cheat detection we are going to talk
about the data and the accuracy which it
isn't very accurate and the misguided
statements that are being made about how
much cheating is happening that part of
it is going to be defended okay that
part of it is going to be defended but
right now we're going to talk about the
fact that there's a reason that people
have been frustrated there's a reason
that people have felt if you want to use
the term
paranoid um there's been a reason that
people have felt like chess.com is doing
enough and that is because what happened
over the years is
that chess.com
investment in the process didn't match
the transparency and the communication
that we were making to the world and
when you add to that the fact that when
we initially invested in sheat detection
everyone it was designed to catch people
before they could even play title
players like that was what the initial
design was because we were just trying
to protect title players then Here Comes
title Tuesday and early Stakes but even
then it's like $1,000 once a month right
so while I would say that the bones of
the algorithm and we've actually been
pretty good at what we've been doing for
a really really long time have you had
the read the Hans Neeman report and
other things that we've done including
earlier in the show we have not done a
very good job of of communicating it
further I would say that when the stakes
have gone up the stakes are no longer
$1,000 once a month on a title Tuesday
the stakes are now millions of dollars
in prizes combined with people feel like
their reputation is at stake when they
stream combined with just general
feelings of frustration when Title
players aren't punished because I'll say
this the the uh the punishment has not
met the crime or what is the right way
for us to say it like we have not
properly invested in what is now at
stake and I'm going to acknowledge that
which is the fact
that people should not be a allowed
chess.com should not be carrying the
chess professional World secrets it is
different if you're a professional
player cheating in a prize event versus
a random person who maybe just learned
chess and even if you know what you're
doing wrong with stockfish it is
different if you earned a chess title
you know what you're doing is wrong
you're stealing from fellow chess
professionals period and you know it
because you have a title even if it's an
NM title that took years to earn in
tournament and when you add the fact
that
we haven't been public enough arguably
we haven't held people as aggressively
accountable as they should be even if I
do believe in second chances and that's
not changing by the way every other
sport has precedent for Second Chances
people get caught for peeds they're not
banned for life they serve their time
and come back if they do it repeatedly
are they banned for life yes that
applies for the Olympics and the ioc or
baseball football whatever so we will
continue to operate with Second Chances
but we are not going to continue to
operate in a world where we are holding
the chess title players
Secrets the strongest players in the
world feel like we're not doing enough
to protect them the stakes are going up
and again the consequences for cheating
have not been high enough on that note I
transition to the biggest point of this
segment which maybe is not what you
thought it was going to be which is that
many of you actually did notice that we
made an update to our legal term on
October 26th in fact some of you some of
the comments we had prepared for the
chat we calling it out on Twitter and uh
making making statements that um
obviously refer to the fact that there
was a massive lawsuit that recently
ended uh but the truth is we've been
ready and prepared and eager to make
these changes for quite some time in
fact it was because there was an ongoing
lawsuit that we needed to be very
patient in that but I will say this we
need the flexibility we need the power
we need the strength to do the things
that you all want us to do so that we
are not constantly running down a bunch
of people suing us when they have
cheated themselves right because make no
mistake regardless of your view of how
the Hans nean thing ended there is no
debate about the fact that he did cheat
he admitted to it himself now you can
debate about the level of cheating that
he admits to or not AR Han NE reporter
him he was dishonest about it that's not
debatable whether you believe our
version of his dishonesty in terms of
what he did competing in prize events or
whether he just kept it secret because
he didn't want to talk about he tried to
pull a Lance Armstrong and say that he
barely cheated right so but but but be
very clear what is UND undebatable is
that he cheated and he was dishonest
about it the only thing that's debatable
is the level of cheating and his
dishonesty our version says it one way
his version says it another way there
may or may not be a documentary on this
someday uh that that is going to tell
another huge part of the story but what
I will say is
this we need the flexibility in the
power to run down everything that you
want us to do and if someone cheats and
lies and then decides to sue no matter
who they are we need the flexibility to
attack it so this is not like chess.com
is protecting their ass so that they
don't get sued again this is us acting
responsibly because we're growing up as
a company and we want to do the things
that you want us to do so massive
validation to Vladimir kronik who's been
frustrated Fabian a Carana people who've
been frustrated and paranoid at times
because of a process that we allowed to
get out of control I am saying this is
our fault and I am saying that we are
now investing even more than you would
ever think we could it starts legally
gives us power title player cheaters be
warned because the game is changing and
you are not going to be have your things
kept secret and I'm going to talk about
the different varying of levels of that
because that's not a threat although
execution will happen in terms of us
acting on what we're what we're saying
we're going to do not any other type of
execution um now moving on to the stats
there's Reddit questions there's people
asking about the stats I'm going to get
into a lot of this with the person who's
about to join me he's our head of
community his name is kasak Corley and
he's
awesome um regardless of everything I
just said and make no mistake this is
all going to be a video that you're
already watching on YouTube chess.com
needs to do better we are investing in
order to allow us to be stronger and
more flexible to do better we have
failed in transparency and process which
is what led to the environment that we
live in with romnick and Fabby and those
other people so there's your full
validation sandwich now in the middle of
that sandwich
is they're wrong about the stats if you
want to look into it yourself you can
look into the you know independent
person this guy named like Damian or
Darion or something who did it you can
believe that we have a signed letter
from head of Statistics at Harvard that
we would use if ever needed to legally
that that that validates and audited our
systems you can look at the fact that no
matter what they say we continue to
close title players every month that
doesn't mean that everything I've ever
said on this show isn't true there are
people cheating on chess and getting
away with it but we are going to catch
them we invest when we think they're
cheating then we run their their other
games we look into their DNA this way we
do this we do that we compare and at
some point they will get caught many of
you who are ogs know that there are
people who cheated and won multiple
title Tuesdays before we close them and
anyone who wants to dive into the Hans
nean report and see the games you can or
or see the names that we didn't mention
we have done really really tough
closures of some of the best players in
the world this idea that b 50% or 20% is
is so outlandishly absurd it's not even
close and in fact as someone who's
sometimes accused of of being a streamer
or content creator first or a hype
person first in hikaro Nakamura he was
actually the most accurate and much
closer if you want an answer and I'm
diving into the Reddit question we have
closed if you want to look at it that
way roughly 1% of people who have played
entitled Tuesdays over time or cheaters
we think that it's that much actually
it's not just titled Tuesday that 1%
applies to like all title games probably
we think that maybe around 3% hikaro
said
4% may be cheating now that's 3% of
either total title player games not just
title Tuesday total cash events but
again that comes with the caveat that we
are aware of anything suspicious we're
on top of it and those people continue
to be closed every month a lot of times
not in a highlight of moment that you
saw in a controversial way we were just
doing our job we're investing and doing
our job so if you look at it in one lane
you can say that's way too high of
cheating 3% I'm actually thinking by way
there are people who disagree with me
that it's even 3% there are people
internally who say no Danny it's closer
to 1% or less I don't know but I would
say this even if it's on the higher
percentage of that and you think 3% is
too much here's what I would challenge
you and this is the last end of the
validation sandwich I validate the
feelings that you have about us do
better but the moment that all the top
10 and 20 players in the world who live
in my Ms want to come forward and say I
would rather Danny I would rather you
have ruined Ali Resa Fu's career who I
accused of cheating you know who you are
I would rather you have ruined Notre
Becka duus aov's career who I accused of
cheating and I won't go down more list I
would rather that because I actually do
think closing three people out of a 100
is a fair thing I'm willing for you to
do that I'm willing to go full Oxo
incident on this and and Mal mentality
in it until you're willing to say that
publicly like the answer is no because I
would actually argue those same stats
protect you every one of you we actually
are doing a phenomenal job anything more
than 3% or even 5% is pure paranoia it
is we're doing we're doing an amazing
job and then if you're willing to you
know kill the innocent sorry for the bad
metaphor right then we'll have a
conversation because until then everyone
else can armchair quarterback their stat
View and we have to act with kindness
and account ability because we have to
assume innocence before guilt regardless
of how people view the stats so there
you go we are investing we are kicking
ass our legal terms are even better
people are not going to lie and cheat
and then be able to sue us in the future
and everything that's being said
currently about our stats is misguided
at best it's just wrong talk to real
statisticians and look at the math and
the data we're doing as well as the
manual stuff that really is very hard
when it comes to catching title players
for cheating where to talk about some of
that as much as we can and with that I
end my scene I drop my I drop my mic we
end this YouTube video by the way
Mittens Doll you can get it if you're
watching this on YouTube